while Russia meanwhile has launched an
air attack on the Ukrainian Capital Kiev
blasts rang out across the City and
surrounding regions there early on
Sunday morning meanwhile Russia says it
foiled Ukrainian attack over the briansk
water region there were no immediate
reports of injuries or casualties well
let's bring in our correspondent today
in besravi he joins us now from the
Ukrainian Capital Zane it really sounds
like it's been a sleepless night for you
all there in Kiev
that is right the military has confirmed
that at least 33 iranian-made Kamikaze
drones were launched from the north of
the country most of them headed for
Central Kiev the military confirms that
it shot down uh 26 and neutralized 26 of
those drones all of them targeting three
districts of the central part of Kiev
this is home to businesses residential
areas diplomatic embassies markets this
is primarily civilian space and what
we've seen overnight is the the mayor
confirming that it caused a fire in an
apartment block at a public park now
what ukrainians say is that these are
primarily civilian spaces there are no
strategic military assets and this is a
continuation of a campaign of fear being
carried out over the Skies of their
country now it is not necessarily the
most intense aerial campaign we've seen
even in the last few weeks but this
nonetheless uh resulted in fire Crews
going out in the middle of the night
around midnight or one in the morning is
when we began to hear loud explosions in
the area of the central part of the city
pictures began to emerge of fire Crews
trying to put out flames of debris and
damaged Vehicles being cleared from the
streets and even though this isn't
necessarily one of the most intense
aerial campaigns as I said it comes on
the heels of this G20 Summit in which a
communique was issued that Ukraine's
allies in this conflict said was a
success that had happened at all but
Ukraine is condemned as not going far
enough in terms of language to criticize
Russia and its actions in this country
there for us live in the Ukrainian
Capital Kiev with all the latest thank
you Zane